Well, and attention,
because from Europe,
and Cara to the upcoming parliamentary elections,
1 very particular request arrives,
the rejection of the commission
wants Taylor Swift to
encourage young people to vote.
Lidia editorial explain this to us.
Yes,
the hero
states that no one mobilizes youth
as well as the young people themselves.
He wants to take advantage of this tour that Taylor Swift is going to do.
throughout Europe next May.
On the 30th he comes to Madrid to encourage
young people to vote in the European Parliament,
because the latest surveys
indicate that the ultra-right would have already become
into the third political force.
Well,
why Taylor Swift?
because She alone,
in the year 2 018.
called to vote
to young people in the 2020 presidential elections.
And she alone got more than 35,000 young people
to register to vote against Donald Trump.